hello i'm dianne bapsky and i serve as
the associate director for library
operations or as we typically call it lo
ello supports the library's dual roles
as a national library and is one of the
27 institutes at the national institutes
of health as a national library we are
responsible for nlm's core functions to
collect preserve and make accessible
biomedical information as one of the
institutes at the nih we support the
nih's mission to foster biomedical
discoveries and innovative research
in all activities we strive to embody
the one nlm concept working together
with our other nlm divisions to support
our collective mission
lo is one of the largest divisions in
nlm
our division includes over 450 federal
and contract staff
interns and volunteers
we have a broad range of subject matter
expertise from library science public
health history of medicine to
terminology and systems
let's move on to vision
responsive to our mission we envision a
future in which data and information
will continue to transform and
accelerate biomedical discovery and
improve health and health care globally
and our values
important to how we operate our core
values our user focus service knowledge
sharing quality and trustworthiness
to succinctly communicate what we do and
why it matters i'd like to introduce
ello's three c's
collect curate and connect
so let's start with our first c collect
we collect by acquiring and maintaining
an international collection from
monographs and manuscripts to serials
and data sets
beyond the physical items in the stacks
our collection includes digital objects
including web archives vocabulary such
as medical subject headings or mesh
full text electronic books digitized
manuscript collections and a data
discovery platform serving bulk and
serialized downloads and apis or
application programming interfaces for
many of our products and services
let's move on to the next c curate
we curate by cataloging indexing
processing and making metadata to make
biomedical information findable and
accessible
and with our final c we connect by
linking our diverse global audience to
nlm products and services for users of
all backgrounds to learn
research and discover information about
health and biomedical matters
ello is also home to nlm's field force
for outreach the network of the national
library of medicine we also host
fellowships for early career librarians
traveling exhibitions to bring nlm
collections to local communities and
other professional and international
partnerships
i hope you learned more about the work
we do in library operations and how your
role contributes to our collective
success
welcome to library operations and
welcome to the national library of
medicine